schön dass Ihr alle bei uns sind zwei
Frauen drei Männer wir erfüllen heute
also perfekt die Quote von
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
aktuell geht nur jeder dritte
Verdienstorden an eine Frau das ist
Steinmeier zu wenig er will eine
Frauenquote von 40% für Verdienstorden
das unser Thema jetzt hier bei viertel
nach acht und ich freue mich dass Sie
alle da sind dann kriegen wir doch auch
endlich einen Orden oder macht ihnen das
Mut vor Kelle nein
ich würde mir wünschen dass Frauen nicht
wegen Quoten sondern äh sondern wegen
dem Respekt den man ihnen entgegenbringt
als selbstverständlich irgendwie die
ihre Orden bekommen und diese ganze
Debatte finde ich immer etwas schwierig
weil wir jetzt sozusagen es bei jeder
Frau die jetzt den Verdienstorden
bekommt werden wir jetzt die Debatte
haben hat sie den jetzt wirklich
verdient oder ist das jetzt wegen einer
Quote ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
vielleicht der Bundespräsident es
einfach tut aber warum muss man
eigentlich dem man nimmt der ganzen
Sache eigentlich wieder einen Wert weil
man jetzt wieder qu auftut und wenn man
jetzt wollen wir jetzt aber wenn ich als
nächstes brauchen wir eine
Migrantenquote für den bundesverdienst
Orden oder wir brauchen eine
Geschlechter diversity Quote und so
weiter man nimmt der ganzen Sache etwas
ich glaube dass wir gesellschaftlich
schon viel weiter sind und
möglicherweise haben wir was aufzuholen
es gibt ja außer auch bei den
bundesverdienstkreuzen aber ich glaube
es hilft der Sache nicht und das hilft
auch den Frauen nicht wenn wir das quasi
immer betonen was wir jetzt alles für
die Frau tun weil sie eine Frau ist ich
möchte nicht in irgendeiner Form
irgendeinen Orten haben weil ich eine
Frau bin sondern weil ich gut bin weil
die Leistung erbracht wird und die
Leistung wird aber offenbar werden zu
wenige Frauen vorgeschlagen Frage hier
in die Runde will er anders schon meine
Frau vorgeschlagen für den Verdienst
[Gelächter]
insofern also allein ohne ist jetzt ins
Klischee Abteil abtreten zu lassen aber
allein wenn man sieht wer sich da
ehrenamtlich engagiert dass er alle die
an der Tafel stehen all die alten
Betreuung machen Aldi auch
Sterbebegleitung machen da gibt es
hunderte 20.000 hier scheint es wirklich
ein Problem zu geben wie man Frauen
tatsächlich immer auch zuschreibt dass
sie weniger selbst über ihre eigenen
Verdienste sprechen und sich einbringen
so dass es weniger Vorschläge gibt für
Frauen die die einen solchen Orden
sicherlich verdient haben ich habe mich
gewundert warum es den 40 Prozent ist
also man macht man 50%
mehr als die Hälfte der Bevölkerung also
50 zu 50 aber was die restlichen 10er
sollen konnten wir keine erklären also
wenn dann halber halbe und ähm ein Punkt
oftmals wird gerade auch Männer so ein
ordentlich vergeben weil sie das
geleistet haben Besonderes im Bereich
sondern weil sie irgendwas gemacht haben
was beruflich adäquat ist glaube jeder
dritte Botschafter kriegt das
Bundesverdienstkreuz nach einer gewissen
Zeit also da gibt es überhaupt keine
Berechtigung für was soll sich die nicht
einfach erarbeiten durch Arbeit sondern
man soll sich in wirklich durch gutes
verdienen und ich glaube da können
Frauen viel viel mehr in die Waagschale
werfen als sie wieder getan haben und
was ist dann mit den Männern Herr mai
fühlen sie sich dann diskriminiert na
gar nicht überhaupt nicht
nein also ich habe nie begriffen wieso
Quoten eigentlich da sein sollen weil
ich immer davon ausgegangen bin ich
gucke nicht auf das Geschlecht sondern
ich gucke ganz einfach darauf
was getan worden ist und da war es mir
völlig egal ob das ein Mann oder eine
Frau getan hat sondern es war wichtig
dass es eine Leistung ist und da kann
ich nur Frau Kelle zustimmen ähm wenn
man es quotiert dann reduziert man auch
die Leistung weil man nämlich eine
Argumentation bringt na ja es ist ja
auch Quote und das finde ich den Frauen
gegenüber überhaupt nicht angemessen und
gerecht schon gar nicht